Okay, long question here. I see that the federal splitted website states that you're no longer practicing. Yes, our website states that I am no longer practicing because legally, you know, I've never practiced, I was never practicing.
But that's one of the things the board is coming up against us and other people about is that we're practicing.
So I had to put that on the website that we're not practicing. Okay, so that's that. So it's just everything that we've been talking about. This person has been on the Zoom calls.
But just go back to what we were talking about way back here about just the different changes and the laws started in November that and that really affected us, you know, with this final rule, the state of Minnesota and December that we just have to really keep everything to the Zoom calls.
Are there two subs? Are these two subs okay for me? Resveratrol and decaf mega green tea extract by life is still a extension. Well, they're not going to get a drink.
So the answer to this is those two products, those two nutrients are totally good for you.
Life extensions resveratrol is just fine. That's what you have in whole recovered. That's just fine. Life extensions decaf mega green tea extract is is not a superior product.
That's a very inferior product in my opinion. I said over and over that green tea extract is the most tainted nutrient on the market of all supplements that exist.
There's only a few companies that I would recommend that you get your green tea extract from and the number one company is the US enzymes brand.
It's called TV go. So TV go from US enzymes is the far superior green tea extract.
They are the most anal company and testing their green tea extracts. I've visited their factory multiple times.
They are the most pure of all the products out there. US enzymes across the board are the most pure products of any supplement company.
And green tea extract is the thing that you have to be most careful about.
Number three, oncologist said I could probably have a low back to be instead of a mastectomy. Well, that is fantastic news. I hope the surgeon agrees.
Well, again, if that if you don't feel comfortable about the surgeon, if they don't agree with that, you can find another surgeon and talk to somebody else.
Well, that's going to January, what we prayed for you about that.
By remaining two words, pretty superficial. No, this person did send me a picture. So.
It's just a piece size. Should I do black sapping in after looking at the picture, I personally wouldn't I would wait and do and have your surgical consults and see what they I just can't imagine that they wouldn't do.
So, I mean, it's so easy that I don't think that any surgeon is going to have an issue with them.
Number five, is it safe to leave the lip builds in after they've had cancer in the.
It depends on who you talk to. So the oncologist and surgeon they're going to always err on the safer.
And they're by the safer side there is radical. The term is radical surgery, radical mastectomy radical because it is radical maybe they're taking way more than they probably should.
And they think that's a good thing.
So you have to find a conservative surgeon that will work with them.
The college just says it, I have a 25% chance of getting.
If I get five to seven, it goes out, how could I save my.
I will say that it's some, I don't know where he pulled that number he or she pulled that number out of.
I don't think there's any really statistics on that that I've seen at least.
But I do think there's a varied degree of lymphedema that people get.
So we've had number of members that have had, you know, 30 to 50 lip builds removed and don't have any lymphedema.
And we've had people that just have.
Or sentinel lymphedema removed and they have some lymphedema, typically not much.
It's usually people that get a lot of lymph builds removed that have a greater degree of lymphedema.
So how could you save your lip builds? That's a discussion you need to have with your surgeon.
They're going to want to air out in a safer side again, according to how they describe that.
But you'll have to talk to your surgeon. You're, you are going to give them consent.
When you sign that consent form that they can do whatever they think is professional.
Once they get you under that I, that's the, that's a sad thing.
So you got to make sure you really trust your surgeon.
Is there any point in doing thermography at this point?
I really don't think so.
You already know what you're dealing with. I don't think there's a need to do thermography unless you just want to get.
Kind of a baseline before your surgery.
Then you can't do it. You have to give yourself at least three months after the surgery, but things to calm down to another one.
That would be the only thing. I mean, it's, they're cheap, but it's in some.
They're not invasive. So I don't keep this anything. I'll go to the next one.